so how do you stay ahead in the midst of
rising competition
on youtube what are the secrets of
creators who don't just have short-term
success
but actually create long-term success
and
legacy on youtube in this video we're
gonna be talking about
three ways creators stay on the cutting
edge
and i'm excited to get into it but if
you are new here the show is called
coffee with cannell my name is sean
cannell
and let's dive straight into the content
and today we're talking about um
a recent article that i saw from harvard
business review
that revealed some shocking data and it
said this there was a survey in 2019 of
3500 managers and it found that only
about
29 of new hires
have all the skills required for their
current roles
let alone for their new ones and
research finds that in key functions
such as finance
it sales positions filled today
will require lean in up to 10 new skills
within 18 months now you might be here
of course because you want to grow your
influence on youtube
you're working on a side hustle you're a
solopreneur you're building out your
business you want to be an entrepreneur
you already are
um and so you might say well i i'm not
in a role at a company
but i think this reveals exactly what we
need to do to stay on the cutting edge
as youtube creators and it gives us data
that every 18 months we need to be
learning at least
10 new skills right that
that right now when you enter into a new
role so by the way if you're gonna get a
new job you're gonna work at a new
career
going into that new career you might
only 29
of people even have all the skills um
let alone future skills that will need
to learn
and that if you want to stay on the edge
here not even on the edge if you just
want to stay at
pace with the speed of how business
is growing especially in tech but all
different industries
you need 10 new skills every 18 months
that means if you want to be ahead of
the curve
you should be learning 10 new skills
every six months and listen
the point of this as we talk about three
strategies in this video
is how much more if you have the
audacity
to go full time on youtube you have the
audacity to stand out in the midst of
rising competition i'm here to cheer you
on
but i'm also here to challenge you to
say you've got to be skilling up
you've got to be leveling up and
learning
and that those that are staying on the
edge of any field
are learning 10 new skills harvard
business
review reveals within 18
months right and so here's the power
question that we ask all the time and
this is kind of like
the vision of our company
is asking this question what skills
do i need to survive and thrive in the
new economy
have you asked that recently like if you
actually sat down and brainstormed
what skills do i need to survive and to
thrive
in the new economy the new economy is
this digital landscape
social media online marketing youtube
what skills do i need to survive
and to thrive in the new economy and a
question for you
is what is one skill you're
intentionally learning right now
do you think that's crazy you know if
you're watching live let me know where
you're watching from
do you think 10 new skills every 18
months is crazy
what is one skill you're working on
right now
as you're here as a part of the live
show because harvard business
review right revealed to us that
in the modern pace of the world which i
realize it can kind of
almost cause some anxiety but
it's just the way things are and our
best insurance for tomorrow
is our continual preparation today
learning new skills
we're gonna be sharing three uh tips on
how to do this
um but we've got some people here we
have rohan he's learning video editing
for his doodle channel video editing
major skill that we need in the uh
modern marketplace especially on youtube
what are some skills
that you want to learn on youtube what's
up joey good to see you right now
time management yeah that's a good one
that's there it's not just technical
skills
personal skills leadership skills um
and ashley thank you for being real
seems like a lot i feel like i never
have time to learn new things
and i encourage you to check out the
most recent episode of the think
me uh marketing podcast because um i'm
empathetic like i'm a new dad
i've i've got a five month old and time
can be really scarce
but actually i would challenge you and i
challenge all of us we don't really
actually have an option
if we want to stay ahead or even just
maintain
in our careers we have to be learning
new skills there's a lot of disruption
happening in the world right now and i
want to encourage you
you're in the right place because you
are if you haven't clicked subscribe
click subscribe here on think
you know marketing uh the youtube
channel or
uh hit like on facebook wherever you're
watching this
and turn on notifications because we're
here to help you skill up it's the
vision of our company we're an education
company
to help you learn new skills sharpen the
saw and stay on the cutting edge
and so what are some of the other skills
though you're working on
we've got david saying learning how to
set dress lighting camera skills
effective b-roll storytelling boom
there's the list
what skills do i need to survive in new
be a new economy
and we want to be intentional not
haphazard or accidental about our
learning
we want to identify that skill and then
run straight towards it so that we can
grow
fast so today we're talking about three
ways uh
successful creators stay on the cutting
edge hit like if you're getting value so
far
and then during the second half of the
show i bring you on the show
to answer your questions and talk about
social media business youtube
um if we're just meeting my name's sean
cannell i've grown a couple youtube
channels
uh across uh different niches um
to a million and beyond subscribers a
couple to a hundred thousand a new
silver play button from another channel
on the way right now
but i'm most proud of our students and
so many people
that have been a part of our online
courses our programs
have started from zero have started
further along and have
actually grown to get that silver play
button so if you
are on a mission to grow your youtube
channel smash the subscribe
button but let's talk about three
successful um
how successful creators stay on the
cutting edge
number one is commit to continuous
learning
commit to continuous learning you know
the first step in anything
is to make a commitment it's not the
only step
but it's this it's the day you make a
decision
to say i'm going to commit to this it's
the day that you say i'm going to put
this on the calendar you haven't done it
yet
like the day i've ran a couple half
marathons and my next challenge is to
run a full marathon
and i haven't put it on the calendar yet
mainly because of the pandemic and there
some of the marathons have been delayed
and i'm just kidding i'm actually um
avoiding the fact that i've been
procrastinating to do it
and i don't want to work hard and it
hurts to run
long distances and there's pain in your
body if i'm really honest
that's why it takes commitment have you
committed to continuous learning
lifelong leaders are lifelong learners
this is in my opinion
data is showing us harvard business
review is revealing
if you want to just stay at a water
level in a pace in any skill set
including being a youtube an independent
content creator
you have to be continuously learning and
learning as many as 10 new skills every
18 months
that starts with a commitment it
actually starts with saying
um i'm going to commit to
being intentional about my personal
growth and about my learning
this is very uncommon i mean it's
possible that maybe that's not not
something that you're
the family you were raised in has
continued to do maybe they kind of
stopped
learning after high school or college a
lot of people once they finish
traditional school they don't read
another book they don't listen to an
audio book they don't get an online
course
they don't continue to learn and level
up this is not necessarily common for
everybody but for those who stay on the
cutting edge with insurance for their
family
for their career for their income
to really recession-proof your life and
to to know that
because and that's a strong word
recession proof
but the reality is if you're someone who
commits to learning
you're gonna be in the top five to ten
percent of just people period
and during any recession there are still
people employed
during any recession there are still
businesses that are succeeding
and i promise you those are going to be
the businesses that are continuing to
learn and to level up
i'm asking you have you committed to
continuous learning have you made a
decision
to say i'm going to become the type of
person that learning becomes a lifestyle
if you have type all in in the comments
or in the live chat just give me an all
in hashtag all in
because number one you got to commit to
continuous learning smash the like
button if you're committed
number two you got to clarify what skill
you should work on next this is really
the next step
because what i've seen and and i'm
really preaching to the choir
if you're here watching this very live
stream or the replay of this
because you're obviously learning right
now i mean we are in education think
media i think marketing
is an education channel so we
uh teach you about youtube teach about
cameras teach about social media
clubhouse like time management even
productivity like we have
we're an education channel so obviously
you're already a learner
somebody who is leveling up and learning
but what i've noticed that holds
a lot of us back including myself is
we're living in an
age of information overload
and information overwhelm because you
may have let me know if you can relate
to this
there's so many youtube videos you want
to learn i don't know what skill to
learn next i'm subscribed to a lot of
good
channels i bought a couple online
courses
i there's a couple free webinars there's
a free challenge coming up
i want to do that oh i want to learn how
to like go viral and
talk and be awesome on youtube and now
there's i want to learn how to crush it
on clubhouse
and we can get torn pulled in so many
different directions
and uh facebook user says yes too much
info
if you want to approve your account you
can click there's a link that allows you
to
approve your account so i can see your
little icon here when i throw it up on
the
screen but i think that's a big
challenge
is number one there's overwhelm chris
says that's a huge problem for me
there's overwhelm with so many different
things to learn and listen
we sometimes try to learn too many
things at once
so if you're trying to get better on
camera
really understand investing in
cryptocurrency
while also trying to become a real
estate investor while also trying to
figure out the youtube algorithm and
optimizing the youtube algorithm
while also trying to learn pottery i
mean maybe that'll help you because you
can relax
and do something after hours you may be
trying to learn too many skills at once
so number two is you need to clarify
what skill you should work on next
this is how successful content creators
stay on the cutting edge
they really think things through and
they think about what
skill would help me reach my next
goal fastest so type in the chat what
skill you think that is for you
but it's actually trying to learn it's
like what skill would move the needle to
get you closest to your goal
for a lot of youtube creators it
probably is video editing
because you're like okay i've got the
video idea i feel somewhat okay to be on
camera
i even shot the footage but it's sitting
on my computer and i'm procrastinating
video editing now we encourage you to
use things like vid chops and you can
check out think media tools
for a lot of our resources you might
delegate that but in this in the
meanwhile you probably need to bite the
bullet and do it
and listen if you would just block the
time on your calendar
to watch heather taurus's tutorial that
is 45 minutes on how to
shoot a video on your smartphone edit on
your smartphone make a thumbnail on your
smartphone and upload it from your
smartphone
and if you block two hours maybe three
to watch that
do it and then implement it after three
hours you will have overcome and target
and crush that skill
but most of us aren't intentional with
our learning like that we're just kind
of taking snippets of information we're
not calendar blocking out
a specific time to learn a specific
skill
it's looking ahead and saying what skill
would help me the most so here's a
question
what what is standing in between you and
taking the next best action in your
business
as a youtube creator if it's if it's
uploading the next video and you're like
i'm just stuck on thumbnails
then block time to watch for youtube
videos
do a skillshare course get the youtube
starter kit
like whatever it is so that you can
target that one skill and knock it down
because eventually
like for me for video editing i mean
i've been video editing for a lot of
years
i don't really got to think about it
doesn't stress me out
because i started video editing in 2003
eventually you learn the skill you get
somewhat competent at it you don't
have to be great at it but it stops
stressing you out it stops reducing your
stealing your willpower your energy it
stops discouraging you because you bit
the bullet you ate the frog
and you just clarified the skill so what
is
the next skill you need to work on and
what's the next smartest skill for you
additionally as you're further down your
entrepreneurship journey
you might know that think media is now
13 people
we're actually hiring by the way if you
want to go to work with think.com and
you think
we have four positions that we're
expanding into
at this point me getting better at video
editing is not the best skill that i
need to work on next because we are
a whole team of content creators so for
me
it might be higher levels of leadership
which i am studying intentionally
or it might be better understanding the
youtube algorithm at a high level in a
strategic level
or it might be monday.com to better
learn how to team management and project
plan
so that the whole team stays organized
it could be time management
team management leadership
it's taxes like this small town kid i'm
a small town kid college dropout started
shooting videos in my bedroom
now i got a multiple seven-figure budget
to manage like
profit loss tax bills
taxed 36 percent you know are we managed
are we
are setting money aside for that what
are tax strategies
how do you set up a trust for your
family
how do you set up corporate structures
so there's s-corps connected to llc's
i we just broke down the matrix here's
the deal what skill do you
need to work on next
successful content creators that stay on
the cutting edge
keep learning skills and they clarify
one skill maybe two skills that they're
going to work on next
so let's see paul says my next challenge
is reaching out to my
potential audience of global english
learners what skill would you need to
learn paul
or what like competency would you need
to level up in that particular case
if you actually want to check out some
of the positions we have at think media
melissa just posted
you can go to workwiththink.com to see
the positions that we are hiring for
chris says learning the algorithms and
driving traffic to my sites
brilliant driving traffic maybe you've
picked up the book from russell brunson
called traffic secrets
which helps you when you know what skill
you need to work on next
it then becomes clear what resources
you should be attracted to it almost
helps you you're watching youtube and
then a thumbnail pops up you're like oh
that's for me because that's the skill i
need to learn you know that's the skill
that um i want to tackle next david says
b-roll
is a challenge for me i'm always getting
loads and thinking about it's all
rubbish i need to become more succinct
and david i don't know if you saw omar's
video on b-roll
but if you type in think media b-roll
you could watch 10 minutes of omar's
video
calendar block out and i hope you're
doing
like calendar planning on something like
google calendar and just say okay
this coming saturday i'm going to block
90 minutes i'm going to watch a video on
b-roll
and then i'm going to i'm going to watch
the video on my phone
play and pause and recreate the scenes
that omar shows me in that video now
you're bringing some structure to your
learning now you're bringing some
structure in terms of the timing in
terms of the place
in terms of some real mentorship and
real practice
and real as opposed to just mindlessly
consuming
because friends sometimes just because
you even have youtube videos on with
information doesn't even
mean you're in a place where you're
really you're really getting it you
might be studying
how to build a funnel how to build a
website how to build a sales page how to
build a sales process
how to build an online course but at
some point you can only take so much
information you need to implement
it's learn and do learn and do learn and
do learn and do
so if it's okay basic funnel let me
build it and get one
working and you'll learn so much by
getting it set up smash like if you're
getting value out of this video so far
and let me know
what skill should you work on next not
that you want to work on next i'm guilty
of this
i want to keep reading actually all
about youtube
which is good because that's also what i
help people with
i want to keep studying youtube at a
deeper level and i should
but there are things like that i'm less
excited about like
business insurance like and so
bill and my wife and i are talking about
business insurance and and insurances
that small businesses
should have i'm not pumped about that
but it's what skill should i be working
on next and who should i be working with
to maybe
learn that skill in this case it's bill
bill's helping me and we're figuring it
out
brings us to number three create a pdp
create a pdp number one commit to
continuous learning number
two clarify what skill you should work
on next number three
create a pdp what does that mean
pdp stands for personal development plan
so let me challenge you if your personal
development plan is not written it's not
real and you're not serious about growth
you're just not like if you haven't made
a plan
you're clearly not a business without a
plan is not serious about business
a youtube channel without a plan is not
serious
maybe you're you're sort of moving
forward but you've probably been
dabbling you're not dominating
if you're gonna really start to dominate
and take
traction and territory with your youtube
channel
read the title of this video this is
three ways successful creators stay on
the cutting edge
and stay at the top this year next year
and even if you're on your journey
up and starting from scratch it's one
thing to reach
it's one thing to get to a level of
success to maintain it
is challenging because things are
changing fast so it's the person
who has an intentional growth plan
also known as a pdp a personal
development
plan and this means it could be the
people you put in your life
the programs you put in your life the
communities you're a part of
the books you're reading how you're
journaling how you're methodically going
about growing in your discipline i've
been listening to
uh one of my favorite freestyle rappers
uh
is going is blowing up on youtube his
name is harry mack if you've never seen
him
cool guy to follow on instagram as well
he's incredible
in in moment by moment freestyle he has
people give him like three
words on omegle and then off of those
three words
he starts to freestyle rap he's really
good at it so he released a video that
was 22 minutes long and this is our
temptation
and in this video he actually talked
about how he practices
with a random world word generator he
sets up constraints like he's not
allowed to use filler bars
and he says he sets up how he's going to
build schemes and he sets some things up
and then he actually practices
intentionally and he says the practice
is different than the performance but
the reason he's so remarkable and going
viral on the performance
is because he's committed to the
practice oh i feel
like there's somebody that today is
going to commit to making a pdp
and commit to making a personal
development plan that's going to help
you accelerate faster than you ever
thought before
because in the past you left your
learning to just haphazard randomness
and maybe that's led to random results
but when you start getting intentional
and structured and you start to actually
plan and practice then all of a sudden
six months later
12 months later 24 months later you're
wondering why you're pulling ahead of
your competitors
you're wondering why oh where did all
where did her skills come from
where did he all of a sudden begin to
man that he's improved
she's improved they've made some wow her
thumbnails are getting better
wow his video hooks are getting stronger
wow that youtube channel was growing wow
that the first 100 videos those weren't
very good
you were practicing use your season in
obscurity to prepare you for popularity
but shoot when did she when did she all
of a sudden glow up and blow up
because she has a pdp she's got a
personal development plan
and guess what happens on the other side
of working your pdp
you get better you get skills you
sharpen your talents you sharpen your
abilities and then your results
any great whenever you see greatness
know that there's
years and hours and five thousand ten
thousand hours of
practice that went behind that
particular skill
and why because i bet you want to get a
silver play button
i bet you want to go full time i bet you
i was just talking to somebody last
month 10 000 a month in adsense
ben grinden friend of mine his his
system is incredible his hustle has been
remarkable he's had a lot of
perseverance
10 grand a month friends in adsense
that's 120k a year that is on the income
stream
and so does that sound awesome well then
what's your pdp
to reverse engineer back from your
financial targets and your
view targets on youtube or whatever it
is
that you're working on create
a personal development plan and with
that
let me just give you a couple ideas as
you're thinking about what is a personal
development plan underneath there
you might want to identify first number
two what skills should you work on next
there's hard skills there's soft skills
there's technical skills there's new
platform
there's software and that's not even all
of them but let's talk about it
so you're trying to identify what skills
do you need
to develop next hard skills
are like accounting now there's a great
book called who not how
maybe your goal is to understand
accounting and hire
an accountant or go to h r block or
go to bench dot com or dot co
which is an online accounting service
you're gonna figure out how you're gonna
solve that problem in your business
accounting or your personal finances
copywriting is a hard skill melissa
caputo on our team
is our lead copywriter that's the power
of writing
persuasive marketing copy and words not
copywriting like erica on our team helps
with
which is preventing yourself from like
copyright protection two different
things can be confusing
data analysis event planning foreign
language fluency
graphic design mathematics seo
information technology
thumbnails how to write a youtube title
hard skills okay what hard skills you
need
soft skills soft skills are maybe
adaptability
soft skills could be your productivity
and maybe it's mindset because maybe you
if you're honest you spend 50 60 70 of
your day
not taking action because you dwell in
your own mind
in self-doubt negativity and loops of
low productivity because you haven't got
the mental toughness
to push through just implementing work
if you were self-aware to reveal that
run straight for it first of all don't
beat yourself up
like it can be really discouraging to
see like holy crap
this is the most discouraging stream
sean's ever done all i realize is i just
don't have skills
in 18 months from now i'm gonna be ten
more skills negative i'm not trying to
make this discouraging
i i i'm trying to actually just help
and talk about the state of the world in
2021 and beyond we got to be skilling up
but it's never going to lead us to a
positive place to like just be like
shoot i got no skills it's just to
identify
man what do i need to grow in target it
and then and then think about how am i
going to attack that
so soft skills are like teamwork
motivation motivation like how to
motivate yourself
leadership decision making creativity
time management conflict resolution
technical skills um or new platforms
could be like i need to learn monday.com
and listen friends
the gray in my beard might show you that
it's hard to teach an old dog new tricks
at 37 years old i don't i hate learning
new software programs i'm freaking with
you
like heather's like you gotta use
monday.com because you're the ceo and
you're setting a bad example
and i'm like no i don't want to use it
and i start
crying like my son sean bradley and i'm
i'm i'm a little i'm
i'm a whiner but i gotta suck it up and
so do you
and you gotta learn new skills because
the new level of our company with
multiple people in it we need tools like
money.com and
slack and google calendar and color
coding the calendar
to communicate amongst each other my
friends
i am a creative probably like a light of
you
i think that time is more like music
it's fluid if someone says be there at
six
i'm like uh what does that mean six
twenty five should be all right
i'm beating two you know i'm dancing to
a beat of my own drum well guess what
apparently that's not what time means
six pm means six pm it doesn't mean
whenever you vibe in
creative person right
so i have to be willing to change i have
to be willing to
learn new skills like time management
but also like
embracing tools i used to i started
think media you want to know how we
communicated
a couple of us first of all it's just me
so i had to first deal with my self-talk
right like i had to first deal with like
motivate myself talk to myself direct
message myself hey sean you need to make
a video today
second then it's like heather kyle
and omar and guess what software we used
facebook
messenger one thread for everything
happening in the business and sonya like
if it was like finances if it was about
a check it was about a video if it was
about correcting a video if it was 30
messages back and forth about refining a
title
one long text thread facebook messenger
thread
was our communication every 18 months
harvard business review revealed that we
need to be learning new skills
10 and i will tell you what we would be
dead at this point in think media if i
was not willing
and thank god for heather taurus to
change
skill up learn google calendar learn
slack
learn some new things and even though
i'm resistant to it technical skills
new platforms i don't know how to use
clubhouse well it's not that hard but
like
and that's probably not your biggest
problem but like learning
you can you got to learn short form
content do you know how to create a real
do you know how to create a tick tock do
you know how to create
short not just how to create it but how
to use it do you even know how to use
instagram
well yeah i'm showing a new other post
but do you like do you look how often do
you look at your instagram insights
that's what i thought never maybe you
need to skill up
saucy saucy coffee with candle day hey
i'm here because i appreciate you
i love you and i really do want to help
technical skills
software picking a piece of software it
friend stop debating what video editing
software you're going to use
freaking pick one and learn it
you could be done with that skill in the
next 48 hours
at least off to the races pick
lumafusion
watch omar's video and stop debating
pick imovie watch the like watch some
free videos on youtube or watch a
skillshare course or something on it
and start making videos if you complain
to me one more time
then i just don't know what video
software i should pick and you've been
researching that for eight months
you are your own worst enemy like you
have to get
past indecision start making some
decisive
moves to pick the skill attack this well
what if i picked the wrong software
what if you do a
decent decision absolute actually
executed is a whole lot better than you
pondering for another three months
on if it's the right camera or if it's
the right thing you're gonna have to
pivot
along the way as you go just start
learning the next critical skill that's
going to help you reach the next goal
that you've set for growing your youtube
channel and your
business you got to create a pdp as we
land the plane hit like
if uh you're getting value today what's
your pdp here's a couple questions
if you've identified what skill you're
going to learn have you
ordered or got from the library or
picked out the audiobooks
of the one to three best books on that
skill set
this is like actually 101 for any
creator that stays on the cutting edge
now to be fair not everybody has to read
i do think that readers
our leaders and leaders or readers
people listen to audiobooks but there's
other ways to learn in today's it could
be identifying a podcast that's all
about one vertical like
if you want to learn funnels you just go
deep in someone's podcast about funnels
but hear me it's pretty smart you want
to go to the cutting edge of an industry
identify the skill and order today
off of amazon the three books with at
least a thousand reviews
each if possible unless it's super niche
so that you actually know there's some
of the best books
that you don't need more than that and
read all three so don't just buy them
actually read them that's a personal
development plan
here's the next three books i'm going to
read what is the next
online course you're going to take we
saw stats that revealed
that there's a productivity boost in
corporations of
30 of a return on investment for every
dollar
a corporation spends on an online course
or online e-learning for their team
for their company they get a 2 900
return on investment how much more
should you be
purchasing and investing in online
courses we right now
there's a 2 000 program on
referrals and how to actually not just
do
go viral on youtube get more views
organic traffic or page traffic it's
about referrals
so i identified that that is the next
skill for where we're at that i want to
invest in and so i'm going to put my
money where my mouth is and i'm
purchasing a 2 000
course i'm not saying you have to
purchase a 2000 i'm just saying
what pdp what is the next online course
you want to take
what's the next skillshare course udemy
course what's the next free
course what's the next three books
you're reading what podcasts are you
listening to
and here's a huge challenge lean in set
pull over i know you're driving and you
shouldn't even be listening to this and
definitely don't be watching me on video
just audio while you're driving
have fufu sit down i know you're on a
walk listen uh
when it comes to your pdp i want you to
actually
stop consuming some content what content
do you need to stop consuming
what do i mean you don't need to be
listening to 10 podcasts when you're
trying to kill one skill
fair enough because if you go man i
gotta i gotta crack the code on this
funnels thing
my online course is done i'm trying to
set up a page i'm trying to build a
funnel
i i need to figure out this kind of
marketing that is the thing i need to do
and that's hard enough as it is
i don't need to be studying nine other
things simultaneously
now of course you're like sean you're a
little saucy today dude
like chill out bro like i get to do what
i want yeah you get to do what you want
like i am not
your dad and i'm not gonna wipe your
butt wow father
talking now this is what it is i wipe
shawn bradley's butt
i'm not gonna wipe yours stay with me
let's focus
uh be you gotta you gotta self you can
do whatever you want
you can listen to 10 podcasts if you
want to but the thing is
legit this is coming from a place of
love if you want to
start creating some serious momentum and
start really
taking down your skills like shooting
down
uh bowling pins with a bb gun
at a carnival if you want to be knocking
down one skill at a time one skill at a
time
or like that get that that old bb gun
cowboy game
where there'd be like little tin targets
ting
ting little targets anybody ever been to
a carnival kind of scary like these
these carnivals that go from town to
town you're like am i to get mugged like
is this a safe place if you want to
shoot down skill by skill by skill by
skill
what are you going to stop reading stop
watching
stop listening to for a season so that
you can get momentum
what books you buying what online
courses you're getting what podcasts are
you listening to
let me give you this question what
online courses have you not done yet
don't buy another online course don't
buy another program don't join another
challenge
don't watch another webinar you already
have information you need to implement
on that you've already studied
but you never closed the loop you never
actually shot you you shot at the little
tin
shoot i missed three times oh squirrel
there's a oh
there's a new strategy that's working to
go viral on facebook let me join that
challenge too
stop the madness keep focused on the one
target and tell ting ting
you start pounding down those targets
because you've
clarified what the next important skill
is in your business your youtube channel
is
and you've created a personal
development plan
for people to join uh
you've created a personal development
plan to tackle
that one skill hey this has been coffee
with cannell
uh we're honest on the show and we've
got people in the house talking about
clubhouse is that latest
biggest squirrel i hope you saw my video
on clubhouse i
i love it i think it's a power platform
powerful platform but the question is
is this the most valuable use of my time
right now and it might not be
because there's something else that will
actually move the needle in your
business
next journey to wellness in the house
sean ain't your daddy i'm not your daddy
you got it you gotta implement these
three tips number one commit to
continuous learning
number two clarify what skill do you
need to work on next
and number three create a personal
development plan
and you can uh uh identify
what is it you're gonna do or are you
gonna join a group
are you gonna be by the way i am a part
of
two prayer groups i'm a part of an
entrepreneur men's prayer group that
meets on zoom on monday mornings at
seven a.m
and i'm a part of a bible study that
meets at tuesdays in las vegas at 5 00
p.m
these are intentional environments that
i'm putting myself in
to continuously learn i believe the
important skill
of spiritual development character
development
connection and community in this case
it's all with men so it's all
growing with other fathers and business
leaders and
i found that those environments keep me
fresh
challenge me are a place where i can be
super real and raw or a place where we
can share burdens together
those are a scheduled time on my
calendar of personal development
when you really have a personal
development plan you have an actual plan
and you have actually actual dates and
you have actual
um you know moments for people
to for for you to develop
your self
my man regan pdp that's right personal
development plan
just larry i love advice on my channel
and i'd pay for it
awesome and appreciate the super chat um
hey today's episode as we get ready for
some q a
uh and if you got a question drop four
question marks and then
post it after is brought to you by
talkwiththink.com
talkwiththink.com um
if you specifically are wondering if any
of our courses events or coaching
programs are right for you
maybe you want some help getting
clarified clarity of where
you are in your journey maybe you're
even like i'm not really sure what the
next best skill
um i gave you a lot of resources today
but we also have
some specific things that we we have
that can help you grow
like for example you might say it's
confidence man i'm scared to get on
camera
i'm kind of i'm also just not motivated
i'm dealing i'm struggling with
motivation
with taking action with self-confidence
your most important account
is not your dogecoin account your
bitcoin account your dick sporting goods
account
or even your bank account i believe your
most important account is your
confidence account
because if you don't have confidence
you'll always find a way to lose
and so when you start growing your
confidence that's when you start
creating
and taking massive action so for example
we have a course called our camera
confidence course
it's not just some random course you
should invest in
but if you were to say i have identified
that like
confidence is a soft skill that i really
really
want to grow on grow in then i'm not i'm
gonna i'm gonna write that down
pick out that resource for it take that
action
invest in that program and you
will begin to experience you know
transformation and and you'll be
attacking
a skill that you predetermined fair
enough so that's what taco thinks all
about
um whether it's that whether it has to
do with youtube
and whatever uh you need help with
our team will help you we don't talk
about we're not going to help you like
have a better garden
but if there's some business questions
you have youtube questions you have
online video live streaming questions
you have you can hear about that
if you want to jump on the phone with
one of our team members go to
talkwiththink.com
link in the description below coffee
with kennel brought to you today
by uh coffee with
no brought to you by talkwiththink.com
with that
i should probably take a sip of the
coffee
as we get ready for q a
and if you got a question go ahead and
drop
four question marks before and after it
uh
sve bartender thank you so much for the
super chat
and uh yeah i think we can i'll do a
quick channel review on that here
uh james if you don't execute your ideas
they'll die amen agree 100
and i appreciate you james and thanks
for being here today let me know your
aha moment from today today's content
was a little bit different
uh i hope you felt my heart and as well
as a little bit
of uh genuine challenging you
um we need coaches man we need people
who aren't going to tell us what we
necessarily want to hear about what we
need to hear and i know for me
sometimes we need to kick in the pants
i'm here to
uncle sean here to uh
to um you know
call you out challenge you and help you
get results
we got s steve the bartender it's not
steve the bartender is this steve the
bartender
no sve bartender
channels steve the bartender must be
your competition
yeah he's got a big channel unless i'm
looking at your icon wrong
uh uh or am i am i right
because i'm not finding the channel
oh there it is there it is fair enough
here we go
awesome okay quick one we're gonna bring
some people on
uh sve bartender
really clean your graphic design is fire
really good
uh banner um
really good photography shockingly good
to be honest
um it's it's absolutely incredible maybe
it looks like some of these cocktail
drinks or whatever uh photo photography
i feel like you didn't take them which
is fine
just because they're so good maybe it
did but like they look like absolute
commercial
um let me see here
25 milliliters of strawberries okay
good so there's like a voiceover
you're showing like real quick answer
okay that's almost like a youtube
short that's interesting this probably
is a youtube short yeah what cocktail
we're making
okay cool i'm glad you're doing youtube
shorts that's cool
um most popular two months ago so
this is great okay six so this is a good
example and hey
add value to everybody here youtube
shorts is a thing uh it's still
very early stage under 60 seconds um
vertical and this one's popping off
on the short shelf no doubt about it 34
000 views
um check the analytics on here see where
traffic's coming from you may be getting
some subscribers i assume you are
uh success leaves clues this is your
most popular video and it's a youtube
short so that's exciting
um and uh the question
of the day for the coffee with kennel
crew is can you
be should you be making shorts can you
be making some shorts
i see you doing a lot of shorts there's
another one so
keep rinsing repeat quite literally
those are crushing so um these top ones
all are at the minute mark that that
signals this one's 21 seconds
at 4 000 views but this one's at a
minute this one's at a minute too so
it's that full recipe short seems to be
doing really well
i love how you did the thumbnails
because it's a full thumbnail and you've
got the actual drink though that very
much fits in the vertical short
um space so i mean
i think that there's a couple things you
have to think about strategically now
and that is there's shorts channels
getting
250 million views a day off shorts
um where's it all gonna go though i
think when you start building that
influence you could start thinking about
brand deals
uh brand sponsorships and just pure
aware awareness but it's probably not
going to make you a lot of money in
adsense
because you only really get the ads when
stuff is watched
on the desktop and not on the shorts
platform at least for now
and it's probably not going to be
something that people would click
affiliate links on because that workflow
is is there's more friction there
um however again if you could get 500
000 subscribers and 100 million shorts
views a month
um that's great 100 million
i think i think i think i meant 250 000
views every day
we at think media get 250 000 views
every two days
off a library of videos that we've
worked hard on for years people with
eight weeks into a shorts channel are
getting 250 000
correction views every day uh which is
leading to just insane impact
um and so i think keep it going keep
experimenting with other content formats
um i i wouldn't i would double down
eventually
on maybe you know
uh other formats but short seems to be
working best for you but this type of
content
would probably have long to i like that
you're using the
the chapters um and and you're really
early on
in your journey uh let's acknowledge
that this is a very competitive space
so i think the encouragement that i
would tell you
and this is actually pretty remarkable
with his many videos 71 000 views
and up 115 17 uploads with the shorts is
definitely helping that
new thousand new subscribers this is um
look at this
coffee with kennel if you're green
if you're going for green if you're
getting green be grateful
um if you're going for green keep it up
you don't need me to tell you anything
like you got 200 growth here 31 percent
i know that's hard to sustain
but like keep it up like any business
any athlete any form of man any church
growth if they were like well we're up
204 percent in attendance and 115
in giving and we're up 31 in uh
leadership morale and we're you know
we're just up in all
directions if that was the case you'd be
like this is going awesome
and then the key would be two things
perseverance and patience
being patient because i know you want to
blow up overnight
and you're probably one video away from
doing that especially with shorts
but perseverance is all the way back to
the continuous learning
skilling up pdp and then just keep
building
because that'll be a compound effect
that i think
continues to get you towards your goals
hey we got maxwell bates on the coffee
with kennel show today
maxwell tell me about your channel
what's your question today um
hello um i'm maxwell bates
and my question is how often should you
be posting
shorts content because it doesn't take
as long to um
make and i i've been taking my videos
that i've been making
the longer form and making them into
shorts and then
also my second question is if you have a
longer form video that's done well in
the past
should you take that video and make it
into a shorts video
and upload that to your channel as a
short
really good question so the question is
youtube shorts
disclaimer um until we've really tested
them at think media i'm only going to
pass along best practices that i've
learned from my friends alex and
benji's testimony and derral eves
number one if you really want to go all
in on shorts
you potentially want to post two to
three a day for a week
then after the first seven days you
could post one a day
forever seven days a week um
i think that exactly your next question
is figuring out content formats the goal
with shorts is not just like oh because
it's a short and because you just
repurposed some random moment of some
other video
that it's going to do well um but of
course it's thinking about
what kind of content we'll do best on
shorts and so testing that and thinking
about that
i think that one of the the coolest
examples of shorts i'll give you some
resources to research
is legal eagle he shoots shorts
five to um uh
three to five at a time he sits down
with a vertical camera
his editor puts together uh he reacts to
things
he talks about trending news stories
and in addition to his long-form videos
he um
is putting out shorts he's figured out
his format and he's creating shorts
natively that's a huge key
he's creating shorts for shorts these
are not repurposed
um my other friend uh ben
schmidt schmidt uh authentic
uh authentic wow and you're watching me
spell
um that's not something you want to see
ben schmacke
his shorts full thumbnail um
and and he is also this is also a native
creative short
so that's something to look at but nice
and clean uh he does some unboxings and
shorts here's one the gopro 9
tripod mount adapter and he again does
kind of a
point of view thing here and that's like
a 60 seconds
stuff you have six sisters
uh like kristen hills uh she
they have a shorts channel and this is a
great example
of pure repurposing and you can notice
that like 350 views like some of them
aren't doing great but here's where you
can tell when a short bus
off into the short shelf um and
it's uh this one 36 000 views
and it's uh scrambled eggs breakfast
muffins and um i think she does a native
intro i'm pretty sure that's
like that's like a actual shorts intro
and then they repurpose a recipe video
from somewhere else
and you can see that especially this is
a brand new channel
dedicated to shorts and um
and you can and and they're able to
sustain that and commit to that and see
which one of these videos pop out
benji travis co-author of the book we
wrote together called
uh youtube secrets is kind of doing
they're not even really tutorial based
they're more like food porn they are
purely just
looking at food and being like i wish
that's what i was eating
um okay that's an actual tutorial and so
watch this
alfredo shorts okay this one's cut or
like best best scrambled eggs
so 55 000 views yes
okay chives that's a little bit of a
tutorial but it's not really amounts
and you just you get the delivery of oh
my gosh benji like that
i need those scrambled eggs in my life
in
30 seconds 55 000 views last time i
checked it was 36
000 views and so that one's doing really
well
compared to let's say this popcorn one
that got 3000 views and based on his
subscribers this one probably has not
got picked up on the shorts
shelf yet another thing to know is that
sometimes it takes
one two three four five weeks for the
videos to show up on the shorts
shelf and that if you are generally
taking action on youtube shorts right
now
you're you're taking action in kind of
the wild west it's more established in
india
there is the ability to create native uh
shorts right from the app
it's not even fully launched in the us
yet um unless it's about to be
but the power is if you start leveraging
shorts
right now you can get some maybe early
videos sucked into
the shorts algorithm how do you do it
you're either putting
shorts in the title or you're putting
hashtag shorts in the description
however there's been studies
people that are testing that are seeing
youtube just knows what it is eventually
and that's whether or not it gets pulled
into the short
shelf and the short shelf when if you
haven't updated your youtube
app and update your youtube app
yeah scroll on your homepage and besides
videos being recommended to you
you'll see not just youtube stories but
you'll
you'll see a short shelf and you can
watch one and the next one will auto
play and you can start
interacting with them and the big
question
you can't really monetize them um you
can if your channel is monetized but the
ads don't play on the short shelf
however
influence comes first income comes
second so what's the big idea and the
big strategy with shorts
is that as scrambled eggs for example
gets recommended to people on the short
shelf
they can press subscribe on benji's
channel
after they do maybe later on they can
watch his how to cook
tonkatsu video where he's actually in
the video some people are uploading
shorts on their main channel
some people are creating a separate
channel our plan at think media is to
start experimenting with two shorts a
week
on our main channel and maybe eventually
start a clips channel um but
disclaimer that is a lot of best
practice
that is solid from others uh but we have
yet to really dive in and test it
uh ourselves should i take my video
that i made a short of and then be like
oh link in the description below to the
full length video
or people are doing that some people are
making shorts
as a preview for their full video
because you can still put put up an end
card at the end that people could tap
takes them into like the full platform
one example
that we're gonna do is like maybe
there's the best lenses for the canon
m50
and there's like 10 of them and that's
like a 10 minute video
but we'll make a short that's like the
top three lenses for the canon m50
that's kind of like quickly deliver the
information it's like if you want to see
the full-length version
click or tap the screen so absolutely
you could put an end
card at the end of your shorts and link
to
uh like another video um
after that what else and then um
other thing is um i have uh
i have a channel that i'm doing with um
my sister who does amer uh
american-based recipes
and then i i was wondering
should i put the metric based recipe on
my other channel because i already have
um my personal channel the maxwell bates
channel for vegan food
and if i'm making videos for that should
i also make a
metric video that i just put on there
because i'm already
doing the voiceover for the other
channel so should i just upload it there
also and change the
metric to from american center to metric
is it the um
is it the same audience um
similar items they're both based around
veganism
um vegan food and predominantly
gluten-free
like health-based living um gluten-free
oil-free um things like that
is it the same audience so because are
you saying metric is in like
international measurement
versus yeah most the most the viewers in
the
on the eating vegan channel which is the
channel with me and my sister
um are mostly american-based viewers
where most of my viewers
from the maxwell-based channel are
mostly international viewers because
i'm a as a college student who
i'm in the multimedia program um
they they teach you all the things in
metric
so i kind of had to learn metrics so i
now become used to that
so i was i was wondering you could
experiment on the same channel to me
it sounds like again i wouldn't really
understand metric i'd have to convert it
so that would say i'm not your ideal
audience
so if you're doing a voiceover with
metric and you have a chance to put that
on another channel i'd consider doing
that and then i would challenge
you as we land the plane that
um i would still the energy it takes to
also
run two channels you could invest into
one and try to really say what is your
biggest audience what's the one audience
really good book by gary keller it's
called the one thing and
and really going after one thing first
i i get it it's cool to do the two but
um you know like i shouldn't upload
two things i shouldn't upload spanish
dubbed
think media videos on the think media
channel because our main audience is
english speaking
now we could we could create a think
media espanol channel
maybe not a terrible idea if there was a
system around it but nevertheless
we have enough problems today as the
size of company we are with 13 people
just staying ahead and maintaining our
current schedule before adding more
complexity
so that's just something friendly advice
is to just think for everybody too
think about like don't spread yourself
too thin so just a thought
i mean if you're if you're trying to
educate everybody that speaks in metric
measurements and every like you're
maybe going too big it's kind of like
expanding territories like if a business
is in the west coast and they're like
let's just expose to central and the
east coast
and businesses fail because of that
because they overextend
like they really did the west coast well
but now they're trying to do too much
just a thought i mean that might be kind
of a huge example for
just running a little spin-off channel
but does that make sense yeah
cool well hey maxwell i appreciate you
did you get value today did i answer
your question yeah i was like i was so
excited i
i've watched your channel for years and
i've always wanted to be on
on here and generally it was always one
during one of my school times
and i would generally be in school but
um i'm going into finals so i
i was like okay well i can do this after
class
uh and so right now um i'll be working
after this i'm going to be working on my
final multimedia project
for which i'm also being uploading to my
youtube channel
for how to make a vegan fettuccine pasta
from scratch
and so it's like i was like i'm so
excited that i was able to talk to you
to you because i have been wondering
these questions and nobody i
talked to at school and the whole
multimedia program as a college student
knew the answers to that
because they're like youtube we don't do
that
and i was like yeah but that's the
biggest is the second world's largest
search engine
come on you're right man i appreciate
that maxwell thank you so much for the
kind words and for coming on today
all right take care um
my friends let's clarify a few things as
you gently
um touch the like button i appreciate
that
uh thomas says i wish i was to the point
where i qualified to do shorts
you don't got to qualify for nothing man
you don't got to beat you at any point
you could start a new channel for short
so how do you qualify for shorts you
don't have to qualify
you just upload them you just upload
short videos
and people who are starting new channels
now pause
if you haven't dominated your current
territory
we have three restaurants in washington
state how about we also expand to oregon
idaho arizona you might over extend
yourself
if you try to like let me just launch 10
new channels hear me massive opportunity
with shorts
is it the best use of your energy right
now could be that's up for you to
determine um you open a new channel
you start uploading less than 60 second
videos
and first week you upload three to five
a day
then you start uploading one a day and
eventually it can pop off and some crazy
short stuff has happened this is what a
short is here's a good example of
garyvee repurposing
uh some content obviously just a clip a
little headline
a little logo down here and then here's
an example at the end
of the fact that it can pop up videos
and take you to another video
and so you can fall into a rabbit hole
of shorts if you will
or even other content the links at the
end could be to other
other shorts or to um
to your full-length videos so that is a
youtube
short it is still developing and you
don't have to
uh qualify for anything shorts has
helped me put out content on my channel
on busy weeks i love that
my friend from snow dogs um
she decided because her main channel was
so established
uh how did i spell this gone with the
snow dogs
her main channel is
okay she's doing some shorts on the main
channel so
here's you know just different shorts my
husky has a question for you hashtag
shorts
so you could check out that and if you
watched the replay of this video if you
just joined there's a couple different
examples
so you can kind of do some research on
on shorts but here's an example of
snow dog shorts with gone with the snow
dogs and she's just putting out 41
seconds
55 seconds 32 second youtube shorts
and then watch this 2.9 million views
what in the last 28 days
12 000 subs 11 uploads because
of the power of shorts and the power of
really cute dogs
so two months ago what happens when
a husky puppy comes out to play in the
snow
and this video went viral 1.3 million
views on shorts
the channel only has 81 000 subscribers
right this one
uh my husky will my husky come inside
during a snowstorm that's pretty funny
right
you gotta admit like that's gonna get
that emotion
too cute the dog sending you all the
feels i'm not responding this is what my
dog sophie does i'm like sophie and she
just stares at me
she's not obedient she doesn't listen to
anything i say
um she is actually the queen of the
house and i'm clearly
who's the dog in the situation i'm
pretty sure it's me um and so
you can see this is a good example of of
shorts really blowing up
and um and just a spin off and let's
look at the cadence
16 hours five days one week one week one
week so that's a couple a week
at this point but there was a season
where she really sprinted on them
so uh hashtag shorts
shorts shelf does the
the can it mess up your stats it'll
reduce the average view duration on your
channel
it's what happened to legal eagle but it
doesn't hurt his channel
because listen the total watch time
minutes went up
even though the average view duration
because the videos are shorter went down
so it did not hurt his channel but it
will mess with your stats
you have to decide do you want to start
a separate channel or not
we again are going to do one here
one there on think media or a couple on
the weekends
um is it a good idea to repurpose igtv
content to youtube amy i tell you how i
do it
i would actually kind of think about
youtube shorts first
i would then oh well okay that's a good
question it's a little bit different
i would go youtube shorts instagram
reels tiktok
that's what we're going to try to
implement at think media and our short
form content maybe not all things in all
places but it's all vertical
you know and so that's one thing we're
thinking
i think igtv content what i'd like to
say amy
if it's if it's under 60 second it's a
short
the better way to think in my opinion is
to repurpose youtube content to igtv
because i believe youtube is a more
powerful more long-term more
search-based platform
and you could take a nice youtube video
and make it that's what this is what we
do
and i would say but your question is
test it
like that's great sounds great to me um
and so here's what i would
just to give you if we're not connected
on instagram hit me up at sean cannell
on instagram
and this is an example of an igtv
so it's two minutes and eight seconds um
and it's this is a youtube video but
then it goes into igtv
format so in my this would not be a
short because it's two minutes so i
wouldn't want to repurpose this in
reverse
i wouldn't want to move this vertical
video to youtube and make it a two
minute youtube video
um i would want to do youtube first and
then go to igtv
next and um we do this kind of stuff
uh this is a minute 24 seconds so none
of these would really be good on
shorts uh and so that's why
tick tock reels youtube shorts 60
seconds or less
i think reals are 15 maybe eventually
you get 30 if you get unlocked
in them or whatever yeah if you want to
connect at sean cannell on instagram
and uh coming up next we got just larry
on the coffee with kennel show just
larry what's your question what's your
channel how can i help
hey uh sean awesome being here man i
have been a fan of yours for literally
years but i've been one of those guys
that
never hit that record button and um
finally
i came and excused my attire i worked
from home so
i had to run downstairs from the office
while i'm in a conference call
on webex and uh kind of snuck out of it
so hopefully they're not calling my name
i appreciate you being here um do you
have a youtube channel did you press
record
yeah i did i did um my channel is just
larry
and um just recently did it now i'm a
former don't hold it against me uh
legislator a
former politician um got into my 20s i'm
your age
and um you know so i always thought i
would wanted to have a channel that
would be uh
more like a political talk show and
somehow i fell into
recently into this um you know uh
true crime type thing because it kind of
fits with politics and
um did some true crime uh live i just
hit live
and um you know we went on and
started discussing some of these true
crime cases and i don't know i mean to
me at least it feels i
kind of been growing fast like literally
but then like amazing
confused and you only you only have a
couple videos out yeah
the other ones were just old ones
my friends coffee with kennel
see i don't even know what that stuff
means yet circle the wagons
pop the champagne look at this
you know we say go for green and we say
you gotta celebrate
you know if you've had a little bit of
growth like wow we're up 13
larry your views are up
25 514
percent you get a car you get a car
everybody raised on
subscribers 2863 so i mean that's just
you could obviously just boom and it's
clearly that last video
that really popped off but uh really
great job it's cool to see that it's
cool you found your niche
thank you thank you i worry though my
question kinda is
i worry now after it's only been like
two weeks and i'm almost at three
thousand subs and
it feels great obviously um
but i kind of worry you know although
i've been obsessed i mean my fiance
wants to i think um
i think she might want to talk to you
next uh sean because with all the stuff
i've bought over the years
uh watching and i fall asleep at night
listening to your uh
shows and you know finally i hit record
but now i'm kind of like all right all
of a sudden all this uh
new people coming in and you know the
messages in the comments i'm forgetting
everything i learned from sean
and i'm saying my gosh what do i do and
is this sustainable
in that niche you know that that true
crime niche is that sustainable
can i still talk about some of the
issues i want to talk about which is
just general like local
not local but national like news issues
or things am i going to turn them people
off
um i'm just really nervous about how to
do that and then also
i guess the last part of the question
i'm sorry it's so loaded i'm just so
excited to talk to you
but um is because i have
my main growth has been because of the
three lives and they're pretty long
do you recommend for some shorter videos
that i repurpose maybe cut them up to
like certain uh
shorter clips that i think are more
relevant
and use those wow well larry um
first of all great job and there's a
couple things we're going to unplug
unpack and i think this is going to be
one of the most important conversations
um for coffee with cannell too because
the first thing that i'm hearing is
dealing with the emotions
of the success and the momentum the
mindset the pressure
secondly the strategy of
what you can do with some of this
content and what you can do moving
forward
so you know first
very interestingly enough i believe this
that
and and this almost sounds like it's
coming from a place
for that that lacks empathy because when
people are struggling when they're not
successful or experiencing momentum they
look at success
and they go oh that is the dream and
that would be easy
um but it is actually once you've been
there
sometimes success can be harder to
handle than failure
or success can just be harder to handle
than stagnation
and that sounds mean to somebody who
hasn't but like when you're
chipping away at your youtube channel
you might go it's easy for
for them to say or it's easy but just
like mace
and biggie taught us mo money mo
problems
you know right like low growth mode and
and of course
if we reverse engineer back like what if
i had the lifestyle of the rich and
famous
there's no question that there's leisure
and there's benefit and there's
privilege
to levels of success but what people
don't realize
is that there's pressure and there's
mental pressure
and there's self-doubt and there's
critics
and there's anxiety
and what we see is we also see a lot of
people who get success
and and i don't even of course
everything's our personal responsibility
but it's actually not success crushes
people success
and i mean we're here to be fair to put
in perspective i mean it's a part you
probably haven't got a million dollars
yet obviously you know like
but like nevertheless it unlocks this
whole type of thing and if i can just go
deeper on that
it's things i've had to deal with
personally and it's things i've seen
heather as she's grown on her channel
and omar
as he's grown is i noticed them where we
put out a video
and maybe we don't necessarily represent
we represent it with integrity but we
don't
represent something right so someone
really starts going at you in the
comments and you get a lot of comments
so now you start thinking shoot did i
let people down
well oh you know you feel the negativity
it's kind of your fault but people are
being mean
and then what happens is it sticks with
you all day long
and it affects your parenting and it
affects your kids
and it affects and you don't want to be
thinking about that at night in your
honey your spouse is like honey are you
with me are you and you're and you're
thinking about
shoot is this sustainable and man that
video is going good but now i'm like on
blast and now people are seeing me
she's like are you present with me and
you're like what what i'm so and like
you know you're trying to
and there's a whole emotional
rollercoaster that's
very real and one of the reasons that
there was this mass of onslaught of like
youtubers burning out and this is an
important conversation just as you rise
and for everybody
to hear that's why i said i think it's
one of the most important conversations
with coffee with kennel
is that we develop the mental toughness
the character the skill sets
the mental even tricks the ability
to decompress and disconnect uh the
ability to have even practices in our
life
and routines and even mantras
that we can shut voices in our life that
can encourage us and speak truth into us
because youtube can
trip your brain out like you just you
all of a sudden
we i'm a small town kid college dropout
right i grew up in marysville washington
arlington washington
when you've got 2 800 and 400
2840 subscribers that's like
four times bigger than the largest
church in my small town if you were like
the pastor
of a 400-person church
and that person would have people being
like i don't like the color of the
carpet and you're trying to please
rebecca
this couple over here is having marital
problems you care about like
you you're and now you've got four times
so in a way it's sort of like the
internet was
partially we as humans we're almost like
never supposed to experience this
and i'm all for this the mission of our
company is to help ten thousand people
create a full-time living doing what
they love while making a difference in
the world with youtube and
experience that success without losing
their soul so that's why i'm so
passionate about this conversation
is because i do believe you can grow and
and experience these things but i hope
i'm empathizing i hope you even feel
some like shoot who else could relate to
me on this
because there's like some real mental
pressure
and emotions that just start hitting you
is that resonating at all
oh my gosh you just said it and
obviously i'm just a micro
you know not even at 3 000 yet and but
it happened so fast literally within a
week and a half
that suddenly my email and being in the
true crime
space is very different it's not so you
get
a lot like my last video i got a lot of
you know really
mixed mostly positive i mean my my
comments are you know my likes are
way above over a thousand likes and so
that's good to know but you do get some
really mean comments and
my i've tried to just outclass them and
and i have a theory that and maybe it'll
change as i
if it grows but is to just
let it stay i don't want to censor
people unless it's bullying or obviously
things like that but
you know just trying to be my theory is
i want to win everyone over
and um and i want to show them that i'm
at least going to do things with
integrity of you even if you disagree
with me
um but you're right it i sit there at
night my fiance is like what are you
doing on that phone put that phone down
i'm like oh my god i got another comment
and i gotta check this and i gotta check
that and
this is crazy i don't know what's going
on like i haven't even had a chance yet
to even go and
i got the invite to monetization and all
that i haven't had a chance to sit down
and do it yet
because i do work a full-time job as
well of course and
i i'm like man this is all a lot and
that's why i'm so glad i got to talk to
you because
i don't know again if it's sustainable
how i should act if i should keep
keep riding this wave and hope it works
out um
i'm glad i hit that excuse me i'm glad i
hit that record button i'll tell you
but you're right i come from although
i'm from new york i'm from upstate
and if you know new york at all i'm in a
small city
medium-sized city you know my last video
just got i looked at it
it had 16 000 views a little while ago
i'm going
i know that's not a lot to you but to me
you know that's a lot
it's i'm like that's a lot to me that's
a quarter of the population of my city
there you go like that's crazy
and i'm thinking i i have a but i have
to be responsible now too
and i got to be careful and i want to do
it the right way i've been watching you
guys so long
that now i'm trying to think back to all
i almost want to go tonight
or this weekend and binge watch every
video from your first
upload and just get a refresher on
everything that i've learned
because it is a lot to take in and
you know i'm and i'm also because i
always
i've got so many cameras that i bought
because of you guys matter of fact i
just bought the uh
m6 mark ii um because
of a video i watched on your channel and
um
i just went with that over the mark the
m50 mark ii
because i figured with the price
difference you're getting so much more
it's like the
mirrorless uh d 90 i think actually
um or 90d i'm sorry but anyways
i haven't even gotten around to using
those because i've been doing the lives
and that's why i was wondering
i want to get some more short form stuff
out that might
you know because if someone's not into
listening to a two-hour live
then there's some good points in there
that i wish they would listen to do
do you do that at all do you ever like
repurpose and clip it up
so by the way quick answer to that
question and you can see him on screen
right now
ruslan is actually doing the live model
long live shows and then chopping it
down into shorter clips the best of
anyone i've seen
we were just on the phone last night for
like an hour and a half and uh check out
his channel
ruslan kd and we're actually having we
have a collab coming up in the next
three weeks or so
where we're going to do some stuff in
regards to live streaming but the the
punch line is
he'll do like a two-hour live show and
take out two
or three or four parts or the hottest
moments and also upload upload those as
well
but i want to kind of land the plane on
just this conversation's really
resonating we can come back to that
um with a lot of people here and and
just give you some advice for the climb
and i want to make a note too
i think this would be a good think
marketing podcast series
melissa how to like handle success
because it's it's just things i've
learned and i just i care about you so
much in our community
um and just some pieces of advice first
of all
know you're just not alone know that
like the emotions and the mindsets
um are are very common for anybody who
starts
experiencing success on youtube second
um know that also don't feel know that
it's a lonely road
like you probably don't feel like it's
lonely now that we're talking but know
that if
that if you are misunderstood by
literally everyone in your life
that that's comes with the territory
that nobody can relate until they can
relate
and nobody understands youtube creators
or people that are putting themselves
out there
um like unless it's another creator
so so connect with that's maybe third
connect with communities
like this and so it's exactly right and
this is reasons why we've also created
communities like video ranking academy
and
that private facebook group and why
heather and tony and our whole team
just because we actually believe one of
the elements
of unstoppable momentum on youtube is
not just content and strategy
that's about 20 of it listen it's the
triangle at the top of the triangle
it's content and strategy that's being
smart knowing your niche good titles
thumbnails
good content cool but the foundation
is another 40 community do you have
people in your life
and for me personally i wouldn't be able
i i'll
i would not be able to be standing
strong on my two feet today
married to my wife sonia faithful
uh mentally healthy
if it wasn't for first and foremost
jesus and just an actual angry
relationship with god and it's my
personal
but actually secondly my being connected
to a local church
where sometimes the pressure i'm feeling
and the mental battles with business and
growth
and you want to talk about the emotions
you're feeling now larry you got so much
success out of you
this doesn't get less complex it gets
more complex because now you're like do
i hire an editor
now there's even more haters now i have
a whole channel that's against me
like it's it but listen but you'll get
stronger
and your mind will get stronger and
you'll be able to handle it
so it's am i am i preparing today for
tomorrow so for me what i say with
communities i feel like you need a
friend group you need a place where you
can decompress
you need a place where you can bounce
things off of people where you can talk
out
your stress and your emotions your
spouse is a great person of course to do
that with
but this is an even better place or
whoever maybe find another youtube
friend or a private facebook group
so i think community but the other part
of that triangle successive strategy 20
community 40 the other one psychology
it's literally mental toughness and if
you haven't it's good for this theme of
today
how successful creators stay on the
cutting edge i think one of the reasons
creators hit burnout
is they don't realize
that you're basically putting yourself
into an environment
it makes me think of of uh daniel
meshach shadrach and abednego
that were in babylon in the book of
daniel and
they were in a culture that was against
that would crush them
and that would cause them to get off
track and so daniel
prayed seven times a day because he was
working on his character
and his focus and his mindset here's
what i've learned
i sometimes need to go on a walk i need
to go on a run
i need to read a book i need to i need
to call a friend
i need to take a nap tapping into
another level of self-awareness
and don't downplay sixteen thou that's
crazy you're it's one-fourth of the town
you grew up in right
yeah and so realizing man there's
sometimes when i need to be working on
my psychology
through it could be through resources
books however you want to do it
but a lot of us don't actually think
about intentionally growing our mental
toughness
but it's one of the things that i think
is required to feel this is the reality
it's
pressure at higher levels there's higher
pressure there's more pressure
at the nba finals when you're supposed
to take the champion winning shot
this is what crushes people at higher
levels too is they start feeling the
pressure
the pressure to live up to your next
upload what if my next upload's only
300 views did i fail
freaking highs and lows that's pressure
and so
i would encourage you then it's working
on um you know that
that mental toughness and then the final
thing to hit the what ifs
definitely check out this week's episode
of the think marketing podcast because
we talk about
about seven different things maybe you
already saw it but the what ifs
kind of matter but they also don't
really matter on the one hand
yes you need to project ahead yes you
need to think about
is is the world changing is my niche
shifting do i need to change my content
that's smart leadership that's smart
entrepreneurship
that's smart youtube creatorship but the
what ifs
are kind of a waste of energy
will this last forever i don't know will
my next video
rank or do well i don't know is true
crime the breast niche what's working
now
will there be some weird haters in the
future i don't know
where will somebody get offended at me
and actually stalk me
they might it's like super scary should
we get adt
yes yes you probably should like at some
point like
will like you know and and that is the
nature of anxiety it's a rocking chair
where we're rocking
it's like trying to solve future
problems that haven't happened yet by
chewing bubble gum
or rocking in a rocking chair that's why
we shouldn't worry about today because
today has enough problems of its own
so there could be a million what ifs
will
you know what if my internet stops
working what if i get hacked
what if i i what if i offend
a computer hacker that's a master of
blockchain
that figures out who i am and then takes
all my money out of my
bank account because i well yeah dude
what if a meteorite hits my town
exactly and if that happens it's not
going to matter and so there are
literally these endless what-ifs and
that goes back to like
mental toughness of saying okay i am in
a negative loop
pattern you know what i mean like what
if what is somebody thinking
like i'm thinking like what if someone
is on our team is mad
what if we get a tax bill we can't
afford what if
our channel gets deleted like i could
literally
drive myself into insanity with what-ifs
and at every level there's going to be
those
varying degrees of pressure so i guess
the final thing easier said than done
is you got to find a way today as you're
growing and you i hope you feel like
you're in good company
anyone who's experienced growth has
experienced these emotions and they
really never necessarily go away but you
can get stronger
you've got to find a way to shut it off
and disconnect
and and in a way kind of be like
what if it doesn't matter you never had
this in the first place
like what if it ends today well then it
might like i don't know
i can't eventually have to let it go
live that life of surrender
and and hang out with your fiance and
just be like yo
and if and and coming from a man who's
probably spent
too many dinners
charged up in anxiety and fear and worry
about what was going to happen
to be like listen you you got you got a
you know a beautiful fiance
you got you know this is incredible like
what if this was the only thing that
happened
bro you can already say you got 35 964
views
and you should celebrate that if you
never get another view
if you never grow again so these are
some of the perspectives and just kind
of thinking like of course
i need to be assertive about my brand
and about my future
but this weekend after i've done my due
diligence and hustled and done this
stuff
you need to find your own process to
disconnect uh
have a sabbath have a day off have a day
of disconnect that's just some advice
because larry hear me you're about to is
it going to keep going
you're going to keep growing it's going
to keep going
there will be ups and downs this is a
roller coaster as someone who said
earlier
but just keep at it but also don't let
it
envelop your whole life all your energy
and all your mind coming from someone
who's been down that path
take some time off have a nice relaxing
drink
with your fiance go on a walk look at
the birds
be thankful for the small things in life
and and
be okay with whatever happens because
literally there's no reason to brag
about tomorrow because we don't know
what tomorrow's going to bring
so there is no promises and there's no
guarantees we could be faithful with
today
and at some point we need to clock out
and check out and that's one of the
problems in our culture in general we're
on our phones 24 7.
there needs to be a time when you put
your phone down and airplane mode it you
should put your
like good book is called deep work or
just generally disconnecting with
technology technology is a tool
don't let it fry out your adrenal glands
over the next 365 days of growth
find those reset times let's land the
plane on this part of the conversation
what do you think so far has that been
resonating
oh my god you nailed every point that
i've been worried about talking about
you obviously know
and what i appreciate about you so much
is despite your massive growth in your
whole teams
you're still so humble and
you still obviously remember the climb
and i i just thank you i really do
um i thank you from the bottom of her i
that definitely hit everything and
i i think my my thing now is i want to
reinvest
in myself because it is something i love
doing i always have that's why i've been
watching i just didn't hit record
but now that i think there might be
something i think i'm going to
reinvest and into a lot of the programs
that you guys offer
with you guys so and that's a good idea
to get around people that like you
your team that has you know
the same mindset so thank you so much
huh
for sure larry well i really i mean i
thank you for bringing this deep
conversation up and i'm glad we went
here
let's just land the plane really quick
on uh on just to answer your question
um check out ruslan's channel um just
because
when you start thinking about how you
could um format some of your own stuff
notice that i think like here's a
four-hour thing it's a four-hour
interview he did that might be like a
four-hour breakdown of
you know for example here's a one hour
and 17 minute thing
but then then he's got 21 minutes 21
minutes 43
13. and we won't go into it here but
he's really developed a system
and here's what's going to rock your
world coffee with kennel
stats 75 uploads this is
the nature of what you're doing is that
when you go live for 90 minutes in fact
we need to do a better job of this on
think marketing
because we're coming up we'll be at two
hours by the end of this thing
and and not a lot of people aren't going
to watch that full replay
but there's definitely like just this
one conversation even if we didn't edit
and turn into another video
we should snip just that part or
whatever and so
there's a whole system that ruslan uses
just with the youtube editor
and again we'll be putting out some
stuff on i can't wait to share that but
you get the general idea
idea here 1.8 million views and 10 000
subscribers but 75 uploads and that
might be like shocking
but again he goes live a couple times
and then he chops those lives down
and that gives them more at bats notice
three thousand views great four thousand
four thousand one thousand or two
thousand
you know great and then twelve
okay fifteen thousand okay hello
and then let's come up here and check
out like most popular
oh sometimes most popular disappears
uploads
past live streams okay i don't know why
i can't see it
maybe because it's a lot of lives or
something but here's 31 000
and 33 000 and that speaks to
um the right topic at the right time
and definitely kind of news based and so
this doesn't work for everybody's niche
this is perfect uh for you
can you can you see that does that make
sense yeah that's great i was
i was making i'm making a mental note
right now to check that out as soon as
i'm done here
i'm gonna check out uh after your show
i'll check his channel out i love that
thank you awesome you got it well hey uh
larry i'm super pumped we got to connect
and uh thank you so much for being a
part of our community and uh
for this question today and congrats on
your success
uh don't don't ever be hard on yourself
like
we can be super negative on our self
words
sticks and stones may break my bones
but words can destroy my life you know
people say words would never hurt me
no they they hurt more than potentially
physical
words any person who did not have a
parent
that spoke life into them but spoke
death into them definitely knows that
words
were painful and of course physical
abuse is wrong but verbal abuse is just
as wrong
and words we just have to be honest with
ourselves to give ourselves grace and
permission if you need to rest
rest if you need to you know work
through something
and i'll have a negative comment that'll
sometimes hit me
and i'll need to talk it through with
heather taurus
on you know the co-host of thick
marketing or omar or somebody else and i
need someone to speak truth into me
because those words can kind of get
under your skin a little bit
and and so get ready for the journey
keep a keep a soft heart but thick skin
and uh you're gonna crush it man you're
built for battle and i'm excited to see
your growth
thank you so much man god bless you i
love your faith too
so bless you i hope you and your wife
and um thank you again
for sure larry appreciate you all right
hey hit like if you've been getting
value today i know we're going
deep on the conversations uh today and
i'm super glad
that we got into um that
um we the channel reviews don't really
cost
i know some people have been doing super
chat and stuff i am not
uh charging for i made
do give you a channel review i'm
thankful for the super chat but that's
not the structure here
um and i would say
that um the the main place where we do
channel reviews is inside of our video
ranking academy um
and so so thank you pick
creation and uh yeah super excited to
collab with ruslan i think we have a
live stream that we're doing together
coming up next week and then we're doing
some stuff in about a month he's coming
on the think marketing part we're gonna
break down
he's doing some really cool stuff you
can go observe it but we'll break down
some stuff in the future and so
definitely
uh follow russon and connect with ruslan
we'll be doing some stuff in the future
he's a live stream master i don't see a
ton of new
innovative things he's doing some really
innovative things
in his approach to the content he's
putting out and 1.6 million views
77 uploads that might seem crazy to you
it's a system
it's like a discipline it's a muscle
he's developed and it's like
and it's a system he's created so
anyways um okay
listen uh smash like if you're getting
value we're gonna hit up
another we're gonna have jeff on in just
a second uh if you do have a question
drop four questions before and after yes
or no on the beard i mean
i've been getting a lot of compliments
it comes down to the fact my wife likes
it
so i mean if she likes it then then i
like it if you know what i'm saying
uh and so my wife likes it ruston told
me i look
like a millennial sage because of like
the gray on the sides too
is that true do i look like a millennial
sage um
i don't know but i'm kind of rocking it
for now
and so uh um
and and my wife likes i've got a couple
compliments i'm trying to figure it out
the beard is fresh troy come on
bring him bill build me up build me
bring it on oh the beard is nice i know
some people are like
ugh you get that that's super funny you
get a lot of encouragement and whatever
of course
everyone's got their opinion the one
other video i'd encourage you to
watch everybody but larry if you're
still here
is you got to watch the fopo video if
you haven't watched
the fopo video you should watch it every
morning
i watch it i watch my own videos
sometimes just to get my mind back in
the right spot
fopo is the fear of other people's
opinions and this 23 minute video
um is is just um
what you can watch it later but use it
as a tool
when you get into time to low confidence
and feeling weak i feel that way a lot
um you know i'll wake up i'll be like
shoot dude internet can be cold man
man that person hated my beard so much
that was very personal
i i we post these comments in our slack
thread
i'll show you um and and so you can see
what really happens at uh
at think media and and what we talk
about in the back end you want to know
if i feel things if i have emotions
if i'm just a rabbit a robot
and so listen to this watch this so i
put this in slack
and i screenshotted this comment on an
old video and it said
this didn't help
which is not that big a deal but i was
like i thought it was kind of funny it's
kind of mean and sharp
and then tony said so tony goes a couple
cry emojis
nolan and tony and he goes something
about that comet just pierces
doesn't even feel worth the time to
properly insult or explain why
and so just know man uh that if you feel
human
good you are human and we're human and
we
are insecure our breath stinks in the
morning
uh we deal with self-doubt insecurity
fear at every level and
um as things go higher man no money mo
problems mo
follow most subscribers no problems mo
views
mo problems like mo
problems and i think that we need to
know we're built for battle
you know when the israelites were gonna
go into the the promised land there the
12 spies were sent into the land
ten said we can't take it and they said
they were small in their own eyes and
they felt like grasshoppers
in their own eyes their self-confidence
and their self-belief
belief was i am small and they saw the
enemy and the
the challenges ahead of them is big but
there was two spies joshua and caleb
that were like nah man
we're gonna take the territory man we're
gonna go in we can take it
god's on our side and there's times when
you're maybe feeling really weak and
emotionally weak
i want to encourage you do whatever you
need to build up your confidence i
believe it's your most important
important account um and your confidence
account
um and and to be self-aware when your
gas tank is low
and when your self-belief is low um
and so this
didn't help you're almost like
dang and here's the crazy thing if you
all haven't heard my friend
john a calf created haters math you
should write this down
haters math this is how haters work on
youtube
99 positive comments
plus one negative comment
equals one negative comment
haters math there's something about the
way our brains are wired
that encouragement is not as
sticky as criticism so encouragement
we're like awesome
okay like button awesome great video
thank you great video and then someone's
like this didn't
help and then all you think about the
rest of the day
is the one negative comment all you
think about
there's a hundred pot there's a hundred
likes but there's four dislikes
and it's that person that waits right
until you upload and as soon as your
video goes live they click
click dislike and you're like who is the
individual
who's made it their life's work in
vendetta and turned on notifications
simply to click click dislike before
they could have ever watched the video
it's haters math it's haters math
friends and you gotta overcome fopo
everyone's gonna have opinions you
cannot please everybody
it's the fear of other people's opinions
and it's your greatest enemy
but that video will give you 23 minutes
of content i dropped a link
um and you got to deal with the fopo man
haters math
okay we got jeff coming on uh jeff
tell me about your channel what's your
question how's it going man
good thanks for having me on sean i
appreciate it i've been a big fan
um i love the this didn't help um i used
to have a
channel where i did a lot more tech
reviews and i've had people come to my
aid and that's one of the best things
about a
comment section is when someone comes
back to help because i made a video
about how to delete a contact from an
iphone
and someone said this video is so dumb
how do you not know how to do this
and the very next comment by someone
else was why are you here
then why are you at a video called how
to delete a contact so huh that's good
correct quick side i love when people
scream because someone will go
everyone in the world knows how to do
this you're the worst creator ever why'd
you even upload this
and then there's 20 comments that are
like thank you so much i didn't know how
to do that
you're so helpful it's opinions man and
and
and i've learned this that there's
actually
two ditches we can fall in we can
actually fall
not just into the ditch of criticism we
can also
fall into the ditch of listening too
much to the encouragement and praise
if we listen too much to encouragement
and praise we've seen this happen to
people who reach success that's the
other pitfall
they go into pride delusion
now it's like i can do no wrong and
usually
right before a guy blows up his marriage
that's what that's the kool-aid he
starts drinking
it's usually he's drinking the kool-aid
of all the praise
and the encouragement and all and and
nobody could give him critical feedback
alternatively the ditch of criticism and
the negative comment
is we start to think i'm the worst and
we get into self-doubt
depression and discouragement and we
don't want to fall into
either of those traps we got to walk the
straight and narrow
knowing what our mission is knowing what
our vision is
acknowledging and saying i can learn
from the criticism i can learn from the
praise
but neither is going to offset where i'm
anchored
my anchor is in my identity and god
alone
and in the mission that i'm called to
and i don't want to be derailed
by either side absolutely absolutely
and uh so i'll get to my question to
kind of you know sum it up
you and i actually have a similar
background um you know i started off in
television and film production i worked
for years doing that as a
production assistant and a camera assist
on
big production shoots uh but i've always
wanted to get into the tech world or
sorry the youtube world
um what i have liked though is i do more
content that i consider like
fiction as opposed to non-fiction com or
content
so i created uh a entertainment and
reaction channel called metal guy reacts
because as you can kind of see
most of my musical taste is in heavy
metal
um so i started reacting stuff i would
never listen to just in that kind of
uh reaction show because they're
obviously massive right now and
there's a lot of very good ones popping
up and there's a lot of very bad ones
popping up so i'm doing my best to
do it in a method that would be very
good so my big question is
is that as opposed to metal guy reacts
should i consider rebranding to myself
because i know that obviously the
long-term play is that people are buying
into me
they're buying into my personality
they're buying into the way i look at
stuff and the way i review stuff
it also would expand things on not just
doing music
because music is kind of you know it's a
tricky one because obviously the vast
majority of my
videos traditionally are demonetized
so i can't monetize them directly so i
have to figure out my own ways of
monetizing it in the future
well incredibly great uh questions
for discussion today and um
really great results what you're doing
is clearly working got the 15 uploads
we got the green 117 here 43
half a million views good point a lot of
demonetized views because of just using
copywritten content and music the most
gets of course flagged or the
monetization of the ads go to the
creator of the song as song scans
um sends it over there um what we're
ultimately talking about
is is vision and strategy um
like this is probably a lot of thoughts
you've had and it'll just be me framing
those same thoughts i would assume
but number one is i actually think
you're off to
you you're doing a really great thing i
think niching down and staying niche
down is incredibly smart
i think that um you
could potentially with even the views
you're starting to get or you're getting
now
you could start be thinking about brand
deals um i think you could start
thinking you know like and this video is
brought to you by
um you know whatever recon earbuds
purple mattress all the things we've
seen on all the channels you know
uh blue light blocking glasses whatever
and so that because
influence comes first and income comes
second and there's big influence on the
other side of this
or maybe it eventually leads to some
other thing you create
affiliate marketing or like your own
course or your own youtube how to
make a react mini course whatever like a
lot of different ways to monetize
um and and and it's really working
and it to me it's a system right it's
literally kind of a template
so it's very sustainable of course you
need to be clever witty
you pick a song you get some inspiration
a joke or two is in there
but it's rinse and repeat fair yep oh
yeah 100
it's it's kind of like a my degrees in
screenwriting and it's kind of like
sitcom writing
where there's just formulas and you plug
into the formula but
again what people are buying into is you
your attitude uh your presence on
cameras what people are buying into
um and i thought you read my mind
another thing i've been thinking as a
mini course because i went from zero to
ten thousand subs in six months
ten thousand to twenty five thousand in
about an additional
three so it's the growth is pretty
exponential i opened the channel in 2018
to reserve it
um but yeah you know i've had some
success on other channels on youtube but
this one was
kind of near and dear so i sat on it for
a little while before putting out my
first video but then
i stuck to about a video a day upload
and i've been almost consistent with
that there's been a few weeks i've had
off but i've been doing almost a video a
day
since but again my format is different
than a lot of people's where
i can build it fairly quickly um in post
and also i have the experience of
actually working in professional video
production
yeah yeah so thing one i think that uh
it's clear it's sustainable it's into a
system it's into a model
that's that's exciting to me because
to me uh that's when
the problem with youtube is if we're on
some kind of a treadmill and we don't
even
this happens for a lot of channels and
it's not bad it's just you don't even
know what you're gonna do next week you
don't ever think about next week you're
just thinking about the next couple days
whereas you sort of can maybe see like i
could keep doing this it's a particular
type of show people like it
cool second will it last
forever or does it hit a lid it it
possibly does
or it probably assuredly does at some
point um
however that's that's when you maybe
i wouldn't even necessarily worry about
it today because you're in so much build
mode
but i would be i'd be like focusing 80
of my energy on today
while spending 20 of my time preparing
for tomorrow
here's like an idea we're actually i
think what we're doing is very
sustainable
but i've even thought about that in my
30s i'm 37 i've wanted to
i really what i really want to do is
talk about personal development
spiritual development business
development it'll be probably on my
channel sean cannell i want to write
books probably do a sean cannell type of
a podcast
i'm not doing any of those things right
now besides maybe in the nuances of like
a coffee with kennel show but
um and i want to do that in my 40s
i didn't want to teach personal
development or business development
until i'd actually built a real business
or it actually developed personally like
if i haven't been able to stay married
and we've been married 15 years
no no no of course i understand those
reasons for marriages to potentially but
you get it
like you got somebody teaching marriage
that is not good at marriage it's that
idea like so
yeah so uh i know that i want to do that
in my 40s point is
i've got fires to put out today i'm not
like really architecting that right now
but i am putting things in place today
for the brand
pivot and not even pivot think media is
becoming a company brand
that eventually will probably be ran by
uh other personalities majority
therefore i will have the margin to be
like sean cannell
um on a decade of personal development
and business development now talking
about we scaled our company
past eight figures we've done as others
we've written the best selling but so i
was doing the stuff
teaching this stuff that's my personal
conviction what's the point
i would just be thinking it might be
someday another
channel it might be the next thing you
do
and you don't even really need to worry
about it but when you hit a hundred
thousand subscribers or quarter million
five hundred thousand
and maybe you start hitting a lid or
maybe you even start thinking
i'm kind of less passionate about it you
don't
want to be thinking about your
retirement plan and not that it's
retirement
at 59 when you retire at 60. it is very
smart to be smart today you don't got to
really hustle
but you set up the right you know does
that make sense so i've been
thinking about hey what's that 2.0 of
this and
uh without letting it take too much
energy from today because i think your
death star energy on growth hacking and
growing this channel is where a lot of
things
should be does that make sense yeah
absolutely and that makes yeah it makes
a ton of sense just to put
continuous effort on what i'm doing now
because that that's kind of been my
thought process in the past too
is just really knuckling down making
sure that this continues to grow
and you know it's it's one thing that
this has proven to
me too is that not only all the vra
stuff is
massively helpful because i do study
trends i do study all the numbers behind
everything to make sure that whatever
content i'm putting out is currently
trending
um it's also just been massively helpful
to
understand what quantity you need to put
out because the quality is always
important
but if you haven't produced like a ton
of videos like a ton of videos
you're nothing's gonna happen and
nothing's gonna move so every time that
i've seen the biggest
upticks because there's always plateaus
my channel grows up up up plateaus up up
up plateaus
and you gotta ride the plateaus but the
times of the upticks hit are when i've
released
four weeks of a video a day including
sundays for
you know a long time so for you know i i
just
something i keep telling my friends that
are also trying to run channels i keep
telling them like guys
quality is important never sacrifice it
but understand
the like quantity you are gonna have to
produce to make a dent
you know um so yeah i'm gonna keep on
the trail of doing that and i love the
idea of just keeping it in mind for the
future
um yeah and i have like i have amazon
set up
for all affiliate links for all the gear
that i have sitting around here
so i got that i get a little bit of
income from that and a few of my videos
were able to stay monetized
so coming up though brands were the
thing i was thinking about some little
shout out in the beginning to a brand
that i can pair with that kind of makes
sense
um either that or i know once i've hit
bigger milestones obviously
merch or patreon as well because i've
had a lot of people ask me to start a
patreon because i get a lot of
blocked videos that i could upload into
patreon
that's starting to grow so a lot of
people you're on the exact right track
you know the the not even today
like pretend i didn't even say this but
like
i wouldn't even necessarily try like i
see all the amazing guitars behind i'm
sure you could make a cool channel
talking about pedals
guitars you know different racks
of amps or whatever else like you could
maybe do that in the future and here's
the thing once you hit some financial
targets
maybe you start working with a
videographer you have somebody helping
with editing
think about this think marketing youtube
channel grew to 22 000 subscribers
rather easily why well because of think
media so it's when you build something
and and i didn't start it until
nine years after i started think media
and i started it with heather and with
tony
so it was just a different season so
again blinders on build the influence
here
and for the the uh monetization on this
channel i
i mean for sure some videos might come
down your patreons
get them uh and and then that's it's
what's the shortest path to revenue
you're on the exact right track
and then what you do with the revenue is
reinvest the revenue in your business to
buy your time back for just more rest
for a healthier pace but also for scale
because that begins to be
because the cool thing too is even if
you took your you know great job 167
views on the weekend video you start
giving some like maybe call to actions
to your other channel
if you wanted case in point if i wanted
this think marketing channel to be like
my main thing just let's
say for example it would be good to
start growing this channel right now
exactly like we're doing in this moment
in a pretty relaxed format like i don't
go live for
one hour 50 minutes and 43 seconds on
think media really
but this is a place where we're we're
kind like this channel is professional
but it's also a channel where we let our
hair down a little bit and our beard
grow out
and and so if
it would be like if i wanted think media
to be able to like support my family
in four years thank god i started
building it
a year ago yeah with the team so
eventually and not right now you hear me
in fact i would put your blinders on at
least until 100 000 subscribers just
build no build get that silver play
button maybe then
kind of reevaluate like journal and get
any creative ideas about your future
yeah out of your head on paper in a
google doc and then go make more videos
you know come on seven a week like just
boom build and build and build another
viral video you're gonna get to 100 000
fast
and and then it's like you could slowly
grow
your next project like you could slowly
grow an email list you could slowly grow
because you're thinking about your
you're like my next project's three
years out
and if people started thinking more
strategically about that then we
wouldn't
it's like saving for a rainy day we
wouldn't be so shocked
when we hit a wall we're like i freaking
hate doing these react videos now
like you know what i mean you're like
dude i've been doing this
for years i i i don't even well
if you started to pivot before it was a
problem
yeah and you wouldn't necessarily have
got into that extreme spot
and that literally happened to me on my
tech channel that you just described
exactly what happened to me on my tech
channel because i started that in like
like 2011 i started a tech channel on
youtube
and just started making the most
ridiculously simple tech tutorials i hit
like eight nine thousand subs got
millions and millions of views and was
bored in like a year i just i hated it
but
i just wouldn't cut the cord i wouldn't
say i could leave it alone so when i
started this one that was a big part of
my dedication was
like you just said i needed some sort of
strategy where if this starts to wear
off i need to be able to figure out how
to pivot
i love it i love it man well hey as we
land the plane
the fourth time flutter map is asked how
did we meet
i mean i think this is our first time
meeting on coffee with kennel but like
yeah
when you got discovered how'd you find
think media and whatever else
i i think it was oh man it's one of the
videos it was one of uh
it was me after the tech channel trying
to figure out how my success had
happened
so i was looking at these videos and i
was like why the heck did this one rank
this one didn't what what's going on so
i think i looked up about
that it was just starting to like look
up how to get views or something simple
like that and one of your videos popped
up
and i looked in got hooked up and then
got vra and it was amazing because
it immediately started to solidify the
strategy i was doing so i didn't know i
was
doing it on the first channel but i
figured oh you know you solidified half
my thoughts
the first 20 of vra i was already doing
um i just didn't know what i was doing
that's amazing jeff
and i uh i'm super pumped we're
connected and uh thanks so much for
coming on the coffee with kennel show
great job too excited to see the rise
awesome thank you so much
all right coffee with kennel smash like
we're gonna take one more person we have
uh
dominica in a second hit the like button
though if you're enjoying today's
episode we are at the two hour grind
it's been a minute since we've been on
coffee with kennel i'm grateful for you
i'm sipping on some um
nespresso
pete's coffee nespresso
bulk pack costco um
and i'll tell ya okay that's a
distraction
but uh coffee with kannel i hope you're
doing well
uh shout out to the vra fam thanks so
much for being here awesome to see that
jeff's a part of that if you want to
learn more about by the way today's
episode
is brought to you by um hit the like
button
is brought to you by talkwiththink.com
if you if you're actually like what's
video ranking academy
what what do you actually do um can you
help me in my unique situation here's
the cool thing about talk with think.com
you'll jump on with one of our team
members on the phone with us
and they might you might be like this is
my niche this is what i'm doing
and if if if we don't know we can help
you for sure
and if our course is not right for you
or one of our programs we'll be like
well good luck you maybe need a
different niche or something but like we
can't help you
like we really we're not just like
trying to sell courses
or you know just trying we really care
about you and we want to make sure
by the way because we want the word of
mouth of people like jeff and the people
like matthew who are like vra's the bomb
so if you jump on talk with think.com
and you can register to schedule a call
right now it's in the u.s uh so if
you're international
best thing to do is to email us at hello
seancannell.com
and our team is there as well and maybe
shoot us a list of questions
but talk with think.com we really want
to get to know about your situation your
niche your thing to find out what's the
best path
and again video ranking academy is
one of our programs but there's a few
other things like we have a starter kit
like there's some
depends on where you are where are you
in your journey how committed are you
how serious
we really care about uh about
um getting to getting to know you so if
you want to talk to
and and finding out if you want to know
if one of our courses
events or coaching programs are right
for you go to
talk with think dot com link in the
description
down below and uh we maybe eventually
will be getting
back to international um we had issues
with scheduling and issues with time
zones and issues with all kinds of
things
we're working on some chat type features
um and so
uh isabel hit up mel in the comments
really quick if you need some more help
um uh live streams
compute with when you go live if you
turn on monetization ahead an ad might
play before you go live
it may play mid-rolls usually not after
the live is over
if you want to turn on multiple ad spots
you could turn on pre-mid
post roll sponsored cards we don't
usually turn that on
um and then that's it and you can
monetize a live stream
um sean what are you even talking about
i'm glad you asked
so this is kind of here's behind the
scenes
of the think marketing channel let me
see if this live stream is monetized i
usually go in i have a video on how to
go live on stream yard highly
recommended
think mediatools.com get some resources
from mel
in the comments right now in regards to
the stream yard tutorial because it
really makes it easy to set things up
so i'm literally live as i'm showing you
this screen and skippable ads
non-skippable ads and overlay ads are
on so this video is already monetized
and i did turn that
on ahead of time now i uh
you know turn on a video or or heather
did a video that was a live stream
a while back and um
after it's over we turned on before
during and after
post roll ads so you could see that
those different ad formats um were were
turned on
here to a live stream and the live
stream replay
is up right now right of like say this
heather video and let's see
it is earned 30 bucks and um
it's a 31 cpm and
it uh has gotten you know
one thousand five hundred views and i
got thirty dollars and twenty cents
on a revenue so far and it's still
getting 82 views
an hour and it got three views no 82
views every two days and i got three
views in the last
60 minutes so that's a little bit of how
um uh live stream works
with or monetization works with live
streams i highly recommend stream yard
i'm using stream yard right now
it is our affiliate link but it gets you
a deal that you don't have to pay full
price
so if you go to thinkmediatools.com you
can use our affiliate link to get
only if you want the pr free ver uh paid
version you can do a
free version of stream yard and it has a
watermark up top so if you look up what
the think is in the upper right hand
corner it's like powered by streamyard
like that would always be there
um and you know we can put our custom
branding up here i use this for like
different shows look at this i can use
it for video influencers you can see
that
if i want to you know pop up a photo of
my wife
with our um when she was pregnant with
our chihuahua
i could do that you know like if if you
want to do that like that's the kind of
power you have with stream yard
um that is a front dog pack and that is
my wife sonia um
before she had sean bradley and that's
my life this is my life
friends um that's what my weekends look
like is this exact situation
that's my chihuahua sophie wow the power
of streamyard you can you can upload
videos and play them like this
ready to get started on youtube but not
sure what gear you need
get your copy of the free ultimate video
gear guide where we share the best
cameras
lighting and audio setup for every
youtube budget visit thinkgearguide.com
to get started today
pretty cool and a lot of high noise
floor on the voiceover of that
and um we you can uh
do a lot of cool things so anyways i
highly recommend stream yard because it
makes live streams sustainable just like
this one
we're doing and it's easy to use even if
you're non-techy
uh really easy learning curve and we
have a couple tutorials
over on the um
think media channel so check out the
comments mel just dropped how you can
try stream yard for free
and um you can check that out and
i highly recommend going live and
especially from what we saw from larry
and and ruslan i think there's some very
interesting
live strategies that we can be doing all
right
hello dominica
stop that's correct yeah it's 10 p.m in
ireland at the moment
so i'm still hanging and uh yeah
accidentally
it pops out on my video i've been binge
watching for the last few weeks and
started my channel
two weeks ago so i wanted to ask for a
bit of feedback
i can see um i watched some videos about
shorts
and some advice so i started doing
shorts
and i can see there are there's a
massive gap
in views you know there's
two thousands of two thousand views yeah
you're comparing this one
yeah so it's a massive gap and i'm just
wondering all the normal videos are not
really picking up
yeah so great so a couple things um
uh i mean success leaves clues and you
want to roll with the momentum
of what you're doing and so uh it's
always good to double down on what's
working and you definitely are seeing
that
i don't think um it negates
like this
don't give me okay let me let me just
first make this statement okay so shorts
can help you get a lot of influence
smart do them
definitely do them however uh i think
like even this colored pencil thing did
you do affiliate marketing with this per
chance
uh it's linked to amazon yes yeah so
this leads to what we'd call an ipa not
the beer
uh an ipa an income producing activity
so somebody can actually run those books
yep
and so and this got 71 views
and you just started so that's the thing
with shorts is shorts
are the now thing and there's the
opportunity to get some
crazy here's why because youtube
is competing with tick tock and
youtube is trying to match tick tock's
viewership
therefore they're pushing shorts to say
our shorts implementation
is getting the same viewership or more
than
than like say tiktok gets on their
platform they may continue to put that
favor towards shorts but they're
definitely doing it right now
so you're making the the right move i
think it's the difference also between
depth and width to a point
uh meaning that uh
width of reaching new people having a
touch point
it's them seeing you maybe a few
subscribers and i would study your
analytics how many subscribers
did that top video drive uh
i think around 15. so it's a big chunk
out of my future 57
so so massive so it's amazing and then
and then it's studying
it's studying this or it's studying the
one that
goes a little bit deeper the most viewed
bigger one and it's starting to look
like okay
four likes still that's real people it's
uh zero dislikes
and then it's and you're super early
stage still so
so uh i mean bottom line is i do think
it's i think it's
both i think it's about the vision of
where you want to take things i think
it's possible to think about
as much as possible it's it's trying to
think things through on the long term
and that could be hard with youtube
because you're all you're like hey
step one survive step two grow
step two i don't even know i'm just
trying to actually like get some
momentum
however eventually we might look back
and be like okay so where am i at you
know what are we doing next where's
where's this all going
and um if you could get a 500 000
subscribe
let's say shorts only channel um
that has a lot of different art projects
looking at maybe other
i mean i'd be studying what you probably
are art
type of short content on tick tock and
and reels and seeing what it is
and what i'd be studying is how they're
monetizing i know there's a creator fund
on tick tock
but even off a lot of views you don't
get paid much but note
go study those art channels and see if
they have brand integrations
if they do see how many views those tick
tocks have
if if blue light blocking glasses
company wants to work with that art
influencer well they would work with you
too if you could get similar viewership
or even a percentage of the viewership
so now you've reverse engineered an
actual business strategy makes sense
tick talker art channel a hundred
thousand views a tick tock
okay cool well maybe i go all in on
shorts because i could get to a hundred
thousand views
hit up the blue light blocking glasses
company and they'll
why would they work with you like if
you're hitting those same numbers
furthermore
if you're dropping those same shorts
first on youtube then tick tock
you could easily start a tick-tock
channel so a lot of people are thinking
shorts only
are then using the same shorts because
they're under 60 seconds on say tik tok
or reels
because now maybe when you pitch a brand
you're able to say
uh that brand integration is going to go
across three platforms in the audience
in all three
the only other thing to reverse engineer
though is do you aspire to do
longer tutorials other things and
maybe those maybe some bigger more
established channels
like us even are thinking about we're
not going to go all in on multiple
shorts on think media
we would start a channel called think
media eclipse but
in the meantime you might do it in
reverse
you might just go all in shorts hit 500
000 subscribers
and now people want to see more of the
talking head more of your personality
whatever because you've built this so
it's kind of up to you any follow up on
that is that making sense
yes i wanted to ask you as well because
i have a physical business for the last
three years so i'm teaching
and i'm also an artist so i do have a
workshop that i'm delivering with
different organizations and we managed
to
move online because of the restrictions
but i wanted to ask you
what would you recommend in terms of an
online platform where would i
actually have my course on would it be
udemy or some other
places so when it comes to like where
should you host your online course
udemy is nice because it's fast
it doesn't cost you anything but if they
end up promoting your course they take a
percentage
and they also don't let you like really
collect your own leads like build your
own email list
um but it can be a nice barrier to entry
and it is a
a a search engine in and of itself
um and you and you all have to look up
their percentages because no matter what
they take a little bit of a percentage
if you use something like kajabi or
thinkific or kartra or click funnels
or teachable you can just compare and
contrast them
the bottom line is like these to
influence servsoft
um these days
they're all kind of the same and they're
not some get bogged down
some load faster some have better uis
but they're probably going to get you
the same end result like people are
going to buy your course or not
if the checkout process works if it's
easy to access your course
so you kind of got to just pick one so
you could price them out but ask
yourself you know what features you need
etc and that is my preference
is to is to get a platform that allows
you to build your own email list
decide if you also wanna some of them
are a little more niche and they don't
necessarily let you build your website
out so that's why we use kajabi
because it's our whole online business
it's our web sites
in fact we're allowed to make multiple
websites on the on the account we're
under
so our conference our growth video live
website's there seancandle.com is there
think media.video is there
courses.shawnchannel.com is there it's
kind of a lot and by the way you're like
well i don't need any of that
good point so it's what exactly is your
vision for what you want to build
what one price is out closest i would
i would i would personally lean towards
thinkific teachable or kajabi i would
probably just to narrow it down compare
those
kajabi is going to probably cost a
little bit more and it has more power
and i would want to build my own email
list up my own
community um and and i
i personally would avoid you to me i've
listened i thought actually about going
back to you to me
for the reason of actually just ranking
on the
platform and getting my content into the
hands of people that are there
because it's its own community so more
power to you
but if i if i wanted to like build my
brand and think about going i would i
would build my own
email list give my own landing page with
some kind of a free gift an
art checklist or an art tutorial or
whatever you're going to do and
i would pick one of those and you follow
up on that
that's great yeah i do have a website i
have actually a few websites for
different sides of the business but um
so there's a
designated one creativity for well-being
and there's
only a link to youtube at the moment but
there will be resources paid and free so
and i started publishing coloring books
for grown-ups
since the last lockdown so just to keep
myself occupied so they're on amazon as
well
and i mean this is pretty cool because
you know thinkific has like a free level
and so you can you can host your content
you can create your course
and then i think what they do is maybe
they take a percentage
at this level because the other thing is
it's nice
to um you don't
have to there's not a lot of risk and
once you start getting momentum
so sales and marketing there's a little
bit of things with integrations at this
point
and then and so you can see this little
dear god there's so many pages uh
compatible with different
how it can integrate with other websites
and custom domains and then obviously it
scales up
teaching site administration
holy security support
pricing yeah i mean there you go so
at the free level zero percent
transaction fees you're gonna pay for
paypal and
stripe or whatever you uh probably and
then
build monthly uh zero zero and then this
one's you know 49 or annually is 39
and at the basic level so yeah thinkific
teachable kajabi
research between them um and
uh if you want to check out our
affiliate links they are at
thinkmediatools.com because in any case
basically it's always smart to go
through somebody's affiliate link
because there's always that discount
it's you know what i mean it'll probably
be like a month free or whatever
and you may be able to find that
elsewhere but just like anybody with a
brand deals like get 10 bucks off or 25
off for your first month all of our
resources like that are at think media
tools if you want to check out some of
our top recommendations for
course hosting what else can i help with
as we land the plane
brilliant that's great yeah that's all
my answers and questions answered so
thanks so much
and what are surprised to be here
tonight
um my dad always talked about
our history being from the isle of man
my re
my relatives i'm a percentage irish
um my favorite song is irish celebration
by macklemore have you ever heard that
brilliant actually my husband is irish
i'm originally from poland but
okay yeah so you're in ireland
um yeah it lasts nine years yes yeah i
love it and so
uh yeah yeah yeah and my dad always had
the isle of man flag
uh all around our house and whatever and
uh man i just really appreciate that we
were able
we're able to connect and thanks so much
for coming on um coffee with cam
thank you amazing thanks so much hey
coffee with kennel
i'm an irishman leather weathered irish
skin
beard orange uh that's macklemore lyrics
i'm not gonna rap okay hit the like
button
but check out action item of the day
watch
irish celebration music video by
macklemore
uh second action item of the day go to
talkwiththink.com if you're curious
about um if any of our courses events or
coaching programs are right for you
um and what skill are you gonna level up
this year does anybody remember what we
started with we are two hours and 20
minutes into the show
friends do you remember what we started
with
the three tips for content creators
that stay on the cutting edge as they
commit to continuous learning
they clarify what skill they should work
on next and then they create a pdp which
is a personal
development plan what skill are you
going to attack right now
what is your personal development plan
what books you're going to read next
audiobooks are you going to read next
what are you studying
if you want to know how we can help
talkwiththink.com links in the
description down below
if you want to um on youtube and then on
facebook you could see on screen
uh talk with think.com or head over to
the think marketing youtube channel if
you haven't subscribed
hit that subscribe button if you haven't
shared the video
let somebody know about that crazy
conversation that just larry and i had
about the emotional rollercoaster of
youtube um if you're grateful
tell me one thing you're grateful for in
the comments
uh ry robio is working on marketing
clarity in fact let me challenge you
what is
what does that mean so marketing in
general but what part of marketing
um is it actually email marketing social
media marketing youtube marketing
uh digital marketing in general but
maybe paid marketing
marketing is a good subject to attack
tackle
but um it's pretty broad maybe a good
place to start is
seth godin's book this is marketing it's
a pretty broad
entry point to the conversation um and
so let me know
what you're working on on your pdp sve
bartender love your content grateful
that you're able to come
on today massive like button smashed
growing the beard out living the dad
life
at you know i don't even know five
months sean bradley's five and a half
months old you want to see
the young legend there he is there's the
little guy
sean bradley cannell um
right now my wife and him are in
washington i'm meeting them soon
hustling on some work stuff this week
there he is at topgolf
um there's sean bradley kennel
on the journey a miracle too we didn't
know if he'd ever be able to have kids
we've been married um 15 years and my
wife
got really sick got a chronic illness at
a couple years into our marriage
and we weren't sure we'd ever be able to
have kids thank god for
some surgeries and some prayer and some
perseverance and so every day
um everywhere we look man we see
miracles and this guy
is such a blessing and uh and we're
super grateful for him
there's that mohawk man the sean bradley
mohawk blowing in the wind like what
and so uh super super grateful
thank you for the congrats that's my
wife sonia cannell
if you want to connect hit me up at
sean cannell on the instagrams
and um and then also
uh talkwiththink.com if you want to
connect
link in the description down below talk
with think.com
let us help you uh figure out that next
stage that next step
uh in growing your youtube channel or
building a business around your youtube
channel
and in the meantime friends keep
crushing it
keep smashing it and remember you gotta
just press record peace